well there's a long and drawn-out
process which is very meticulous and it
looks not only at what the level of loss
and the disability of the patient is but
also what their abilities are in terms
of what they can cope with what they
understand what they're likely to what
they're likely to be able to face and
aware of adversity and overcome and of
course crucial to everything is the
biological suitability they have to be
suitable immunologically for a hand
transplant and very often that is the
barrier we we have have most trouble
with and what about a case like the boy
in Baltimore how does it differ when
you've got a child involved we decided
and I think most units have heard have
decided not to extend the program for
children I think in the light of the
United States experience and Scott
Levin's experience there we will
continue to review that the big
difference between had adults and
children from the point view of hand
transplantation is firstly of course
they have to understand and be compliant
and have some idea of what they're
getting into and and that's a standard
we applied in the adult population but
also in a child you have all all all the
issues surrounding growth and the
effects of the immunosuppressive drugs
upon growth and their health so there's
a more there's a more complex balance
between the gains and the disadvantages
but I would just add one thing which is
that the gains in a child are
potentially substantially more because
of the very great way in which they
rehabilitate and heal so potentially
that means there could be a greater
chance of success but what about the
transplanted hands themselves do they
age and grow along with the child they
will age and they will grow with the
child because presumably the child and
and from from what I know I spoke with
with one of the team yesterday in the
United States the the match
in terms of age and size is very good
and I would expect the biological age of
the hands to continue to age at the same
rate as the biological age of the child
and take us through the actual procedure
itself because obviously a very
painstaking and lengthy operation
involved well yes we should probably
just summarize it the the first thing is
that you're you're you're alerted the
presence of a donor who is potentially
suitable and then we go through a
rigorous process of cross matching and
establishing the AMIA logical and and
are the physical suitability the
retrieval of the organs then takes place
along with the retrieval of other organs
that are that are gifted by that in in
individual and at the same time the
recipient either adult or child will
will be in the operating theatre and
prepared and then the two come together
and the two teens those that retrieve
the organs and those that prepare the
child then then unite to become one team
and then it's really just routine
microsurgery it's joining up the bones
the tendons the vessels or nerves it's
it's what we do day in day out and what
then are the chances of success and what
sort of functionality do you expect
someone would double hand transplant to
have eventually in the in the well
matched individual with the well
executed surgery at the correct level
excuse me for hedging it with all of
those those caveats III would expect
rapid return of some function and slower
but good return of other function in our
transplant that will took place two and
a half years ago mark who's the the
recipient has now gained extremely good
auto automatic use of his hand with
good Sensibility fine motor movement
power and control in a child I would
expect the recovery to be very much
quicker and very much more complete but
as one of your potential patients was
telling us earlier there is involved in
this isn't there a lifetime of aftercare
it is a lifetime both after care exactly
as if you had a renal transplant or or
or a liver transplant and of course
exactly the same as if you had not
official in way which is a lifetime of
maintenance and care and and repair the
limb so when you lose a limb whatever
modality you choose who supplant it and
replace it you have a lifetime
commitment to the aftercare of your
device or your limb and the management
of your reduced ability you mentioned
there you spoken to one of the team
involved in the transplant in Baltimore
how does it make you and your team feel
seeing that success I'm extremely
pleased for them I think it's it's a
wonderful team they're there they're
extremely diligent and and very
competent they haven't had the barriers
that we have in terms the organization
to deal with as far as I can tell where
we're at in Great Britain is that having
conducted the first transplant we're now
with NHS England who are being extremely
extremely far about the process of
commissioning this surgery we're now
going through the process of
understanding who will do the surgery
and on what type of case and I'm pleased
to say that specialist commissioners in
Britain have now agreed that Hamm
transplantation will be commissioned
encouraging news special simon case been
great to talk to here is very
encouraging